NARRATOR: The
Mediterranean Sea, 2000,
a group of divers working
off the Egyptian coast
near Alexandria discovered the
submerged ruins of statues and
even entire temple complexes.
One instance of the discovery
of something that we thought
was legendary was the
discovery of Heracleion,
Thonis, near Alexandria.
We had read about this in
Greek myth and Greek histories.
We had no evidence
for it, and then
one day, it gets discovered.
NARRATOR: Dating back
to the 7th century
BC, Thonis, or Heracleion as
it was known to the Greeks,
was cited in ancient
myths as a major trading
post for the region.
For a long time, Heracleion
in Egypt was in many stories
but had not been found
until the year 2000.
In India, in the year 2001,
something similar happened.
The Mahabharata
tells of the time
Lord Krishna built a great
fortified city, Dwarka,
but was thought to be
an imaginary place,
and then it was discovered.
NARRATOR: But of all the places
on earth that were thought
to be mythological, the one
that has inspired the most
fascination and has
proven the most elusive
is not a city but an
entire continent, Atlantis.
As described by Plato in
the fourth century AD,
Atlantis was the home of a
highly advanced civilization
which mysteriously
disappeared into the ocean
thousands of years ago.
While mainstream scholars
continue to dismiss Atlantis
as nothing more than
a fanciful myth,
there are many who
believe Plato's account
was based on a very real place.
But if Atlantis, like other
formerly mythical locations,
were discovered,
would it offer proof
of extraterrestrial
contact with early humans?
Dunedin, New Zealand,
February, 2017,
scientists at New Zealand's
top geological Institute GNS
Science announced the
discovery of a lost continent,
one that sunk into the
ocean millions of years ago.
They dubbed the land mass
Zealandia, as it extends
directly under New Zealand.
Although it is almost
entirely underwater,
it fits the definition
of a continent,
as it consists of an
intact piece of crust that
is distinctly different
from the ocean floor
and clearly separated
from Australia.
This was a shocking
discovery, because they
thought the number of
continents on earth
had been basically fixed.
Now, this one looks
like it could have been
another continent, where
perhaps human beings dwelt,
and if it was, this
could certainly
rewrite a lot of history books.
NARRATOR: Could this be the
lost continent of Atlantis?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say that it
is a distinct possibility.
There is an ongoing
bias among scientists
that anything from
the ancient past
must therefore be a made
up fake story, a myth,
and yet these scientists
have to look at the reality,
that archaeological
discoveries are
verifying that the actual
stories have merit.